Hoy se celebra en todo el mundo el Día
Internacional de la paz fechada
establecida por la ONU como el día
dedicado al fortalecimiento de los
ideales de paz a través de la
observación por 24 horas de una no
violencia y un alto el fuego a pesar de
los esfuerzos mundiales cada día son más
los conflictos en el globo vamos a
analizarlo con Eric Fajardo él es el
profesor e investigador universitario
especialista en análisis de conflicto
Gracias Eric por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 muy buena
mañana le pregunto en este mundo tan
convulso muchos conflictos
internacionales activos en este momento
que se necesita realmente para lograr
esta Paz mundial que hace muchísimo
tiempo pues está pidiendo es imposible
es una utopía pues lograr esta Paz
mundial
bien al parecer con la globalidad y la
declaración en el 81 de este día
internacional de la paz se había logrado
concertar un ideal de vivir en una
armonía y en un balance llamémosle así
geopolítico importante en el planeta sin
embargo lejos de fortalecerse la idea
del convencionalismo el multilateralismo
como la base de este acuerdo de Naciones
para la paz se ha ido debilitando en las
últimas décadas hoy día diría yo que la
paz como ideal al menos como ideal de un
convencionalismo de la convicción y el
compromiso de los estados de ser parte
de una Sociedad De Naciones y de una
estructura de regulación de
preceptos Internacionales y principios
internacionales de derecho se está
disolviendo se está
digámoslo así haciendo melting en en la
realidad política que más bien nos
muestra una re radicalización de los
estados una generación de nuevo de
bloques de poder antagónicos y y con
ello por supuesto lo que en los 60s y 70
se conocía como una nueva guerra fría un
distanciamiento posicional de visiones
doctrinales completamente desencontradas
y esas visiones además tienen una efecto
una secuencia de debilitamiento de este
multilateralismo de esta posibilidad de
una conversación y de una voluntad de
los estados de Rendirse o de entregarse
a la posibilidad de ser regentados de
alguna manera fiscalizados y por
supuesto en forzados a cumplir con los
preceptos de paz desde estructuras
multinacionales o multi convencionales
Erick ante todo esto como quedan
organismos internacionales como por
ejemplo Naciones Unidas que Precisamente
en este momento pues se lleva a cabo la
asamblea número 77 con los discursos de
líderes mundiales y los jefes de estado
serían estos organismos cada vez más
obsoletos que tienen que hacer para que
realmente pues funcionen todo lo que se
habla y realmente llegar a acuerdos que
tengan pues
propiedad no y pues la disposición de
poder solventar estos conflictos bien si
usted observa en el estudio del discurso
nada más en el análisis del discurso de
Gutiérrez en la actualidad yendo hacia
bakimón y un poco más hacia atrás a los
grandes líderes de este esto que se
llamó la Sociedad De Naciones o el
multilateralismo va a haber querido un
declinar permanente y sostenido de
liderazgo de estos individuos de la
capacidad de quienes están a cargo de
las instituciones convencionales o Supra
estatales de poder tener autoridad
autoridad moral primero Pienso que ha
habido un importante desgaste de la oea
en el período en el cual emergieron
todas aquellas denuncias usted recordará
sobre su participación en este negocio
con Irak en los 90s de Bueno pues era
prácticamente una transacción para
permitirles tener ventajas en torno a un
acuerdo de acceso a los entonces a
cambio de gas otro eje de desgaste
importante fue el surgimiento de estas
visiones encontradas y del remerger de
los totalitarismos ha habido una fuerte
tendencia a debilitar estos organismos Y
eso se ha testificado para mí entender
en estos últimos días en la asamblea
general de las Naciones Unidas es una
especie de desencuentro de discursos
monológicos diría yo una torre de Babel
cada uno tiene una narrativa
completamente distante de una percepción
general de una percepción digamos lo así
compartida sobre el estado de situación
de las relaciones internacionales he
escuchado al presidente boric Él no
entiende Como una derrota o como un
fracaso ni siquiera como un traspié el
resultado del referéndum hay una especie
de embriaguez retórica de otros líderes
de igual manera en su alocución ayer el
presidente de Bolivia les decía con
bastante Claridad Que para él el sistema
de Justicia que cinco organismos
internacionales han observado en ese
país era completamente independiente por
su lado el presidente nayib bukele del
Salvador con convencimiento Real decía
que él estaba dirigiendo un país que él
lo había transformado en el más seguro
del continente conclusión cada uno de
ellos tiene una narrativa yo diría
dicotómica absolutamente
autista Y desprendida de lo que es una
lectura general del estado de situación
la paz en esta perspectiva La Paz en
este escenario Es simple y sencillamente
improbable Erick vamos a volver al
conflicto Internacional del momento
donde por supuesto también en todos los
líderes mundiales Ana pues dicho algún
comentario sobre por supuesto la guerra
en Ucrania porque precisamente hoy en el
Día Internacional de la Paz o para la
paz para buscar una paz estable duradera
en todo el mundo el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin anunció una movilización
de 300.000 reservistas para ir a luchar
a los territorios o ucranianos a qué
lectura también le merece esto este
anuncio del presidente es Vladimir Putin
y hasta dónde estamos en este conflicto
ucraniano que parece no tener fin
bien desde el año 81 Esta es la fecha en
la que supuestamente se hace un alto al
fuego de 24 horas simbólico no solamente
como una muestra del compromiso de los
estados por la paz como objetivo final
en las relaciones entre entre todos
ellos sino además como una muestra de
respeto Por la autoridad de este
convencionalismo en el que estamos
hablando de este multilateralismo lo de
Putin es para mí una señal clara es un
síntoma claro de cuán poco ya interesa
el estar de acuerdo en el marco de una
Sociedad De Naciones de una asamblea
general y cuán poco autoridad ya le
queda a estos elementos de carácter
convencional o transnacional que
intentan ajustar fiscalizar observar en
ocasiones también en forzar el derecho
internacional no hay ningún tipo de
autoridad ya no hay autoridad moral Pero
tampoco autoridad coercitiva que te haga
pensar que es posible que los estados
específicamente aquellos que tienen la
tendencia a la autoritarismo y a
desmarcarse de los Derechos Humanos de
las libertades civiles y de todo aquello
que compone la carta Interamericana o
los acuerdos internacionales de respeto
a principios básicos de democracia
internacional vayan a respetar esos
acuerdos es lamentable pero como tú bien
lo señalas es también una muestra una
evidencia del estado de deterioro de la
idea de El convencionalismo y de la Paz
como objetivo de este convencionalismo
muy rápidamente Eric ya para finalizar
30 segundos La amenaza nuclear el
presidente Putin también lo volvió a
poner sobre la mesa
definitivamente es una amenaza creciente
y no solo del lado de Rusia me preocupa
muchísimo también la idea del acuerdo
nuclear de los Estados Unidos con Irán
hay sin duda un alejarse un
distanciamiento de los bloques de poder
en el mundo y en este soliloquio de cada
uno en este monólogo de cada uno por
supuesto La amenaza incipiente es la
amenaza nuclear es una cosa que nos
tiene preocupados a todos